so let's assume that this entire square
represents a hole and we can see that
part of it is shaded in in blue what
we're going to do in this video is try
to represent the part that is shaded in
blue as a fraction as a decimal decimal
decimal and as a percent so pause the
video and see if you can do that well
let's first think about it as a fraction
so the hole is split into one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten equal
sections and six of them are filled in
so the blue represents six tenths of a
hole or represents you could say just
say six tenths and you could also
rewrite that if you divide the numerator
and the denominator by two that's the
same thing as three over five
fair enough now let's represent it as a
decimal
what decimal would be pause the video
again and see if you can do that well
six tenths we could literally just go to
our place value so that's the ones place
we have a decimal and then you have your
tenths place and so we have six tenths
so you could just put it right over
there we are putting a six in the tenths
place to represent six tenths now what
about a percentage well percent means
per hundred so one way to think about it
is six over 10 is the same thing as what
per hundred that is equal to if we
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 10 that's the same thing
as 60 per hundred or another way of
thinking about it 60 / instead of
hundred you could say cent and so this
would be equal to this would be equal to
sixty percent let's do another example
so here once again our entire square
represents a whole so see if you can
represent this as the part that's shaded
in blue as a fraction
the video and do that well you can see
that this is a 10 by 10 grid so there's
a hundred equal sections here a hundred
equal sections each of these squares
represents one hundredth and how many of
them are there let's see this is this
row is 10 20 30 40 and then 1 2 3 4 so
this is 44 over a hundred forty-four
hundredths and we could actually
represent this in other ways we could
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 4 in which case you would get 11 over
25 that's another way to represent this
same fraction now what about as a
decimal
well 44 hundredths you could say well
you have your ones place and then this
is the same thing you literally just say
this is 44 hundreds this is another way
of representing 40 400s it's 4 tenths
and 4 hundredths is 44 hundredths and
then if you were to do a percent well
this is 44 per hundred or 44 hundredths
but even here I like I like looking at
it as 44 per hundred or 44 percent so
this is going to be 44 percent and we're
done